anytime a rich person tells you that
money doesn't make you happy just ask
them for their money then like cool cool
cool I guess it's useless right can I
just give me a bunch of it then all
right
[Music]
fellas welcome to the Friday episode The
Boys reactor and go through some news
stories uh let's start with the thing
that everyone is talking about everyone
is always talking about which is Elon
Elon has gotten himself in trouble a
couple times this week first he tried
selling some house plants or office
plants I should say uh to his employees
to raise money wait really and then also
uh ridiculed and sort of kind of fired
an employee who uh who is disabled uh
your thoughts on the endless drama of
you on
cringe what do you think yeah Elon is is
the cringe Master he has to make
everything about him uh like it's just
me me he's now known as milon musk in my
house this guy this guy's too much the
the crazy thing Sam did you watch this
all go down with the the guy that was
like hey am I fired I think we should we
should explain this yeah so do a recap I
I didn't understand all that at first I
had to like click so guy goes on Twitter
uh who's got I never heard of this guy
but he's got like 150 000 followers and
he says Hey nine days ago I lost access
to my work computer just can't I can't
access Twitter anymore I work at Twitter
I can't access my work my work computer
doesn't log in anymore it doesn't work
can't get into my email can't do
anything
um I'm not sure if I'm fired nobody told
me I'm fired but I just can't get into
my email or my computer I've emailed
them I've waited nine days I've got no
reply from HR from my you know from
anybody
um so I'm guessing hey at Elon Musk am I
fired
and so the you know he tweets that out
was he getting paid still
I don't I don't know I don't think so
because everybody was whatever it was
only nine days so maybe it was he hadn't
got it got in between yet so he tweets
that out and he goes maybe if this gets
enough retweets then
um you know then I'll get a response so
it gets retweeted a bunch of like
because people you know there's the
whole uh group of people that you know
love to hate Elon myself included and so
people are like this is another example
of you know how poorly Twitter's being
run right now like why why would you if
you're gonna fire somebody tell them
they're fired that's you know common
decency right like I feel like elon's
got this flow chart
where
it's like I'm firing this person should
I tell them it's like yes and it's like
no no I'm gonna go with no okay what
happens after no like should I just
should I um you know you know meet with
them in person
it's like uh dude he's like Irish good
buying their jobs it's basically it's
just walking out without saying exactly
and so anyways this thing gets um
this thing goes viral so basically uh
Elon then you know again
he sees all he sees this thing going
viral so instead of
um
instead of uh instead of actually just
eBay you are fired or confirmed yes you
you were you were fired he instead says
um what have you been working on like
what have you accomplished is the uh so
then he goes well if I you know if I say
what I'm working on I think I'd be
breaking my NDA do I have permission to
break my NDA and tell you what like can
I say publicly here what I work on
anyone replies yes go ahead
so dude what a pathetic start to the
story that's already pathetic he goes
all right well the guy goes well I was
you know leveling up the design of this
I was working on this and
um you know I was helping save money on
this contract or whatever and
um and he goes Elon replies level up the
design from what to what you know
pictures or it didn't happen and like yo
[__] you cut off his computer access
how is he supposed to have screenshots
of his work if you took away his
computer he's not even able to do it and
um and then he's like mocking him
basically he's just replying with like
the crying laughing emoji he's replying
trolling him with like a clip from
Office Space and
now here's where Elon went wrong so
elon's not dumb
but he's a dumbass and there's a big
difference between dumb and a dumbass
dumb is you're just not smart dumbasses
you're smart but you do dumb things and
that's what Elon does here so he
basically picks on a guy that it comes
out so this guy sold his company to
Twitter
and
the guy so Elon comes out and he hears
what he says about the guy he goes he
goes somebody was like dude this is the
uh this guy Alex Cohen had this great
tweet he goes I'm not gonna lie this is
the most entertaining exit interview
ever because watching this whole thing
go down in public and then the guy and
Elon says the reality is this is a guy
that who was independently wealthy did
no actual work and claimed as an excuse
that he has a disability preventing him
from typing yet here he is tweeting out
tweeting up a storm wait so and so the
disability thing Elon said that first he
goes he claimed as his excuse that he
has a disability preventing him from
typing yet was simultaneously tweeting
up a storm I can't say I have a lot of
respect for that what a douche why could
how could he even feel that here's the
other side of the story
this guy has like this guy's in a
wheelchair he's had like muscles
muscular dystrophy for 25 years and so
he goes so this guy came back with just
kind of some fire so he goes uh
Thunderclap I think you call this yeah
he did a solo Thunderclap basically so
he comes back he goes
glad to see you're taking such an
interest in my health
um I assume what you're talking about
when you are sharing my private health
information online is the fact that I've
had muscular dystrophy for 25 years and
I guess I'll go ahead and tell the story
now so you know I lost I lost the
ability to use my legs 20 years ago I've
been in a wheelchair
um unfortunately it's been spreading and
I've my my arms have been getting weaker
over time in fact that's why I sold my
company remember you said I was
independently wealthy I guess what you
mean by that is I built a successful
company and sold it unlike you know
somebody else who might have inheralded
inherited a emerald mine which is you
know how elon's dad owned an emerald
mine which is [__] which is that's a
[__] thing people say but whatever a
good step we'll use it in this case it's
good
um and so he goes I guess that's what
you mean by independently wealthy and
you know so here's what here's the story
this guy's got muscular dystrophy he
he's losing feeling and or strength in
his arms it's becoming very painful to
to type he decides okay I'm gonna sell
my company and instead of taking a lump
sum payment
he chose to get paid out uh through like
a salary instead of an upfront money
which is like dude who would do that why
because he wanted to pay more taxes in
Iceland where he's from or I think it's
Iceland maybe yeah yeah I think it's
nice wait really more taxes why do you
want to pay more taxes because he felt
like he's as a disabled person he had
benefited a lot from like the social
welfare system there and was like I want
to contribute as much as I can to that
which honestly sounds like too good to
be true like
that's so different than me I almost
can't fathom that I'm almost like why
don't you just take the money and donate
it instead of paying taxes I don't
understand that but either way uh this
guy so build a company had 100 employees
working for him it was profitable it
decides to sell it
um you know he he's his body's basically
been giving out on them he's like you
know financially it wasn't the best
decision uh my company was making a lot
of money Twitter's offer was lower than
other companies but I made a bet on
Twitter it was growing at the time
um and he goes by the way he goes
anyways I digress are you still reading
or is your bathroom break over okay what
was I saying and he goes um hey oh yes
uh so you bought the company told
employees you weren't firing them firing
75 of them and then you did I was not in
the first batch or the second batch or
the third batch of layoffs I don't know
which batch we're on map now but I you
know uh whatever you know I think I got
I think I'm fired now I'm not sure I
just want to make sure I get paid out
because in his contract he had it where
okay I'll take the money as a yearly
salary rather than an upfront payment
but if you ever fire me then you have to
pay out the rest right so I'm guaranteed
this money I'll take it you know slower
rather than faster but you know that
that's fine and so anyways this guy this
guy not only he not only he says how
he's typing what's that he also
mentioned how he was typing yeah I think
he was just like yeah I can't do like
sustain thing but like I can type with
one finger on my phone and uh blah blah
and so anyways he explains this he goes
um
like this guy was literally named person
of the year in Iceland this guy like his
his side hustle is he's building
wheelchair ramps throughout Iceland so
that other disabled people could he's
building hundreds of these wheelchair
ramps like that's who you're that's who
you're picking on here that's who that's
who you chose to to fight with I saw
this great quote he goes
Elon man this guy's a dumbass he [__]
with the wheelchair Mr Rogers and he
goes he goes what is this guy thinking
uh you know like and so this guy you
know I read this thread and I was
literally like
hmm 911 I'd like to report a murder
right like you know it was just like the
ultimate clap back and then Elon tries
to backtrack and he basically goes um
some random dude Tweets in the thread
goes I know Hallie and this is you know
you're saying that he's a liar and was
just trying to do no work and get paid
out and that's not who this guy is
random guy tweets and then Elon reads
back this is the most [__] of all
the [__] he goes based on that
comment I decided to call Hallie rather
than
um rather than just tweet it to each
other and um
he goes I decided to call Hallie uh uh
and he goes
um what did he say he goes and you know
have a video chat with him turns out you
know there was a misunderstanding the
information I was given was either
incorrect or correct but not important
that's that white flag bro you you lost
you know
uh you know we've discussed him you know
staying with the company
and you know this is the ultimate
backtrack it's like first of all you you
want him to stay with the company
because you have to pay him out if you
fire him so that's like you know the
first thing second thing you basically
[__] up and stepped in it and this guy
could sue you for like you know a whole
bunch of money for like basically you
know discriminating against a disabled
person as well as disclosing his private
health information as well as probably
three or four other you know issues that
were that were you know labor laws that
were broken in this process
but it's like dude
you decided to have a video chat not
when the guy said he's you know your
employee said he hasn't heard from you
not when he you know asked one for an
explanation
um but when a random guy on Twitter said
no hell he's a good guy you decided
there to stop in your tracks and do a
video call with him [__] like this
all this whole thing is [__] and
Elon continues to be you know king the
king of [__] have you heard the uh
the song damn it feels good to be a
gangster
sure you hear that song
there's a line there's a line in it I
can't say the real line but it basically
says uh real gangsters don't flex nuts
because real gangsters know they got
them and right now elon's he he is
pretty gangster I mean he's the man he
ain't acting like it he's flexing nuts
hard and he shouldn't be flexing as hard
as he is and uh I get the personality
type where some people are like dude
he's just saying whatever he wants the
same thing with Trump or he's like he's
just saying what he's just like it is
says it like it is and I I actually
dislike that uh I like that like to an
extent but I'm like there's but just
because you say it like it like well
he's just doing what he wants yeah but
he just you just punch someone like
hitting people isn't good yeah do you
know what I mean it's like yeah I want
to do what I want does that mean I want
to like go take a dump in the corner of
the room like you know there's like do
you let's be polite to one another also
if possible right we don't we're not
going to be needlessly needlessly rude
to one another and that's kind of how I
feel he acts right now and that's not
cool two other two other parts of this
new story one it's going around that
this guy's payout was 100 million
dollars which makes no sense anybody
who's in business is like well that
number makes no sense there's no way
he's getting paid nine million dollars a
year of salary there's no way that they
bought his Agency for 100 million
dollars it's not how much you would Aqua
hire an agency for it's probably more
like 10. but it'll and I went I found it
it just started with some random guy who
goes oh man Elon backtracking now
because he realized he that Hallie has a
100 million dollar payout and like 5
Tweets in somebody's like where'd you
read the 100 million I've never saw that
he goes I'm just estimating like you
know Aqua hours are a million dollars
ahead they had 100 employees so you know
100 million dollars and now that's just
like in a bunch of places it's like
that's how that's how bad like
information spreads how fake News starts
the second thing is Elon owned himself
when he goes the end of his thing he
goes better to talk better to
communicate through talking instead of
communicating on Twitter it's like just
literally [__] on his own platform
by the way like you know so so
self-owning you know all around
um so that I thought that was
interesting and then Ben said this other
thing about the house the office plant
thing
what do you make of this I mean this
makes no sense what happened I didn't
dude I I muted Elon I I love what elon's
doing man but I like I even think the
Twitter thing's interesting but [__]
it's hard to be on his team and so I had
to mute him he so he's been selling like
office furniture and memorabilia from
the office like just liquidating to like
get more cash I tried buying they had a
Twitter logo I tried buying it but it
got up too high and apparently like
there was like plants in the office that
he tried selling to an engineer like one
of the employees or something like that
it's like
I mean I don't know either this guy's a
marketing genius he's trying to get PR
like trying to like it's the thing where
it's Amazon was like we use doors as
desks to save money which is a [__]
it's either one of those just like
stories that sounds like man he's really
turning over every Rock to save money
from this this bleeding company by the
way I tried doing that an Ikea desk is
significantly cheaper than a door from
Home Depot exactly I've tried doing this
a desk is way cheap doors yeah
you can't even like write on them so so
I don't know what to make of the story
but just sounds like it just makes no
sense either he's lost his mind or
there's a masterful PR thing that's like
9000 IQ and I can't understand it or
someone's just making things up I don't
understand
uh maybe maybe all I think all of those
things could be true an exaggeration
about a weird thing he said because he's
lost his mind and makes for good PR
gotcha that and he's a genius it could
be all those things you know he could be
he's he's not dumb but he's a dumbass
that's a that's a great line I saw
people call him Elmo Elmo mosque and I
thought that was pretty funny uh but no
he's he's [__] up do you want to do
one more yeah what else you got all
right let's go with uh with money and
happiness guys so uh there was a 2010
paper that said that basically above
seventy thousand dollars more money does
not make you more hap does not make you
more happy turns out Mo Money less
problems because a new study says that
that is completely untrue it starts to
flatten a little bit as it goes up but
what do you guys think of this I I so
here I I'm pulling this up so here's
what it says Sean um it says that um
so if you are in the happiest of the
unhappiest 20 does Plateau after
reaching a hundred thousand dollars but
after that if you're not in that group
more money does mean more happiness and
uh and it basically it goes all the way
up they studied it all the way up to
five hundred thousand dollars and they
said after that we we really didn't
study it much but up to five hundred
thousand dollars people do get happier
but that said the researchers found that
the overall emotional effect of more
money on a person is small compared to
other circumstances it's even compared
to a weekend approximately a fourfold
difference in income so four times your
income is equal to the effect of a
weekend which is kind of funny wow um
but that said
more money makes you happy so and this
is all like there's this like 2010 study
where it said seventy thousand dollars
from the beginning I thought that was
the most [__] study and I've done
this pod so many times that's nonsense
that is absolutely not true seventy
thousand dollars my sister when she was
like younger lived in New York for
seventy thousand dollars you're
basically below the poverty line that is
not happy
um so 70 000 not a chance I used to say
I thought it was at like 250 I actually
believe it could be 500 or even more but
you get happier this is one of those
things like um
you know that might be true I when I
heard this study I was like that might
be true
I'm gonna go ahead and test for myself
like I don't know if the Earth is flat
around I don't really have the ability
to go out there and check it out I don't
know you know if uh if sulfur gas is
poisonous but I figure yeah no need to
test that
this is one of those scientific claims
that I had just decided a long time ago
I'm gonna go ahead and check I'm gonna
go ahead and do my own research on this
one and uh and go ahead try to go get go
get a bunch of money and see how it
feels and uh you know what I'm glad I
did because the study was [__]
dude I got an MRI yesterday and the lady
at the front desk was like all right
that's 750 and she was like didn't say
that she just handed me that she goes
there's a bill today and she showed it
to me she thought that I was gonna like
freak out and I was like all right you
take Apple pay and I just scanned my
card or whatever and I remember thinking
you're like where do I tip I am yeah
I remember thinking I am so happy I'm in
a spot I used to not be able to afford
that at all and I'm so happy I'm in a
spot I call that you know what I call
that I call that braces money I'm just
gonna be able to swipe my card and get
my kid braces and not think twice about
it when I was younger my parents bought
me braces and they told me that it was
two grand that they had to pay on a
credit card and at the time they had
like six thousand dollars and I remember
thinking like God damn that sucks right
like that's not I would be a lot happier
if I had nine million dollars in the
bank as opposed to nine thousand dollars
or whatever you guys had
anytime a rich person tells you that
money doesn't make you happy just ask
them for their money then like cool cool
cool I guess it's useless right can I
just give me a bunch of it then right
like you know yeah dude and let's let's
look at the actions uh versus the words
in a lot of these cases right there's I
always thought this study was [__]
also because
I I wonder how much money the people
making this study make I was always like
yeah that's what they think sure they
think that because I want to know how
much bias goes into a study when the
it's always the researcher's salary
well that's
that's it yeah or they're like making
only 50 and they're like hey C boss 70
000.
um
but I've always wondered what like the
biases are because uh like I don't know
I haven't even wondered I'm like this is
obvious this is obviously not true and
uh you know if I get to the finish line
and I realize hey you know 5 million and
10 million felt the same well shame on
me for going the extra mile
do you know another thing have you ever
tried to read a study yeah dude
studies are the talks are crazy yes it's
hard I have no idea and then I'll like I
follow all these like smart like a
huberman or like these other guys who
like break down studies and I'm like and
they'll say like well this study's
actually [__] for this reason and
I'm like I guess I'll believe you but I
don't like I can't read this and they'll
like say like studies that I'm like well
it said the word study in it it must be
true and they're like no no it's
actually way off for this reason and
like their sample size was like eight
people was it colleges or uh you know a
bunch of bunch of different things like
that dude I don't know how to read
anything or there's a chart and it's
like the error bars are huge it's like
yeah it's that plus or minus you know
it's 70 000 plus or minus 500 000 it's
like whoa okay hold on what's going on
here right so so yeah I think
science is uh
is used as a like a shield for like you
can't argue sometimes
um in many cases and there's good
science and there's bad science and
there's weak science and there's strong
science and there's you know and then
there's physics where it's like you know
empirically true
um but the only thing that I know is
three things there's good signs there's
bad science and I don't know the
difference between the two that's like
the only that's the only shirt right
there nice that's like the only truth
that I know it exists I'm just that was
a little too
big old brain
look at that big brain on today all
right what else we got got that big
brain all right here we go
let's go Tick Tock uh Biden
Administration in conjunction with
Congress they're evaluating a new law
that would make it possible for
companies to be banned that pose a
national security risk people think this
means that they're going to ban Tick
Tock what do you guys think should
demand tick talk I don't know anything
about that
wow that's why they pay you the big
bucks
dude like people talk about I don't I
don't know anything about China I don't
know what they're doing that's true uh
do you no no honestly I do not I mean
how would I how would I really know
um so I think that being able to ban
something if it's a national security
risk yeah I think that's
fine I think that sounds like
appropriate uh I also by using Tick Tock
a ton I can totally see how
I wouldn't want this in the hands of my
enemy it's like oh the ability to like
take in all of my data my camera roll
turn my microphone my camera on as well
as feed me spoon feed me any amount of
any like feed of information based on
you know a mysterious algorithm that can
Surface good stuff bad stuff weird stuff
misinformation whatever like that's a
pretty powerful weapon right so so I
definitely see the Merit in that now is
Tick Tock actually a threat I don't all
right what's the next one
[Music]
where's the worst heavy
heavy actually looks gorgeous I think I
love our new CRM our software is the
best HubSpot grow better
all right next one uh let's go with
favorite cities a new poll from a real
estate advice website reveals where
Americans would move if Money Was No
Object New York Austin's in there that
makes sense also on the list though Las
Vegas and at number nine Baltimore dude
I'm from St Louis I'm from the city of
St Louis A lot of people don't know this
but if you look at what the highest
murder rate per 100 000 people and it's
been St Louis like either it's usually
number one sometimes number two for the
past 10 years there's like 500 murders a
year
St Louis and Baltimore very similar
sucks it sucks I don't want to move
there not at all I don't understand that
that's weird to me once I worked in the
media business I realized that uh polls
rankings lists all [__] just things
to get generate clicks links controversy
you know if I was going to make a list
and I made a list that was like you just
nod and you said yeah that makes sense
you're not going to share that you're
not going to talk about that I throw
Baltimore as the this fourth most
desired city to live in or whatever like
put New York now you just make them
outraged guess what I'm gonna get a lot
more clicks a lot more discussion a lot
more controversy and a lot more
backlinks for my SEO and you know so so
once you know their incentives you'll
know why these lists are often
outrageous either they're just paid to
put like you know things on the top or
they're trying to do things that will
generate a bunch of shares
do you uh do you know what state
Baltimore's in yeah Baltimore is in
Maryland
all right nice I didn't think you'd get
that if you Google if you Google
Baltimore to let my breath in I was like
of course I know that
Baltimore dude
Google Baltimore and look at the images
very very unimpressive and not not
impressive at all I'm sorry Baltimore
that Skyline not interesting one bit
the the tourist Association needs to
work on their SEO not not so good uh
what else you got bad can we wrap this
up with the slap fighting one yeah do it
do the story Sam
so Dana White is putting muscle behind
UFC uh sorry Dana White and the UFC is
putting muscle behind power slap league
so if you guys have not seen this it's
basically two guys they're typically
like huge fat guys standing at a table
smacking each other I think they get
three times the smack when they get the
three times to smack each other I don't
know the rules but it seems like someone
gets knocked out every slap every fight
yeah right what are the rules is it like
the first one knocked out yeah loses or
typically three to five rounds they take
turns hitting each other in the face
with an open hand and
um the other person should just stand
there and take it they get 60 seconds to
recover and then
they can earn up to 10 points based on
the effectiveness of the slap and the
defender's reaction oh that's good so
you know I like things where you get
rewarded for pretending like it didn't
hurt uh because that's a skill that I I
honed as a little sibling for many many
years
um dude this is the stupidest thing on
Earth I don't know so look am I I'm not
a woke guy I consider myself right of
Center maybe I'm getting more woke as I
get older I'm hating on nylon and also
this slap thing is the stupidest thing
on Earth and I'm not gonna give it any
of my eye I'm not gonna give it any of
my eyeballs I'd prefer to see two people
in their underwear fighting to the death
in front of a million people like UFC
but the slab thing not a fan yeah like
you know to me knockouts are like dip
it's like you know I like chips and dip
but if you take the chips away and it's
just dip now I feel a little dirty
that's how I feel about this like I'm
cool watching a fight where somebody
gets knocked out because their skill and
there's defense and then there's
strategy when it's literally you have to
stand still and get hit as hard as you
can by somebody else
um now you I'm just you know now I'm
just eating barbecue sauce and I I don't
really which is kind of
which is kind of ridiculous that it's
considered okay that we can use a we can
use a you know chip as a spoon and with
cheese but when you just use a spoon as
a spoon for that cheese it's we consider
two different things that is a little
weird isn't it big questions in life
that I might spend a whole lifetime
trying to wonder why we are the way we
are in this way now let me tell you
something that's a great example Michael
Vick like got booted out of the NFL and
like went to jail for a dog fighting
ring
Colin Kaepernick can't get a job because
he you know took a knee during the
national anthem too those two are not
even remotely the same thing by the way
I'm just saying people have got a lot
more punished for a lot less than this
how is Dana White not like how is he not
canceled for doing this how is this
legitimate thing that they're allowed to
do
um kind of insane to me that like
you could you could get away with doing
this and not others I I guess it's
because they're consenting adults
and that's that's the line I guess
anything above that line works I don't
know that sounds a little a little iffy
to me but uh yeah I think this is so
stupid I'm not going to give it I try
not to give it my attention I can't
stand it I think it's really dumb and
they're all like I watched the trailer I
was heavily entertained by it so you
know this is from the trailer it's kind
of like there's this subreddit called
watch people die and it was like videos
of people killing themselves and it was
huge and people were obsessed with it
and then they deleted it and I remember
thinking that's a good idea to delete
that and yet it was really hard not to
go to that subreddit it's like it's it
was impossible like when you see it when
I would see it come up I'm like oh my
God this is horrible I cannot watch this
and I would have to look away I had to
stop myself from like clicking some of
that stuff
let's finish with a little show
recommendation have you watched physical
100 on Netflix you keep telling me to
watch it no oh my God everybody needs to
go watch the show and I'm gonna warn you
it's a weird show if you had just
described it to me I would not have
watched it it's just that Korean Netflix
thing in real life right
it's squid games in real life yeah kind
of so basically here's here's why it's
amazing so the premise of the show is
they got a hundred athletes of different
types so bodybuilders MMA guys boxers
women men small large gymnasts Ice
Climbers luge people from the Olympics
um whatever everything wrestlers and
they put them all together and they walk
in and it's basically like we're gonna
see who is the mighty of athletic
competitions
um like who is the overall what is the
best body what is the perfect body is it
this guy or is it this girl or is it
this guy and and so
and like the very first like you know
competition they have is basically
there's a ball in the middle of a mud
pit it's like Whoever has this ball at
the end of three minutes wins and it'll
be guyver's girl it'll be giant
bodybuilder versus there's no weight
class and no nothing and they go there
but they're but the best part is it
doesn't have this American tackiness
like slap fighting or Ranch like Koreans
don't eat that [__] they don't do that
stuff all these people here's the three
reasons why it's amazing number one they
got legit the best athletes so they
literally got like the guy from the
World's Strongest Man they're Olympians
gold medalists like their most famous
MMA fighters like they got their most
famous athletes to go do this reality
show it's like if LeBron was competing
against Patrick Mahomes versus competing
against Serena Williams but like they
actually and they not only they show up
they actually gave a [__] like they were
like I really want to win this and so
they weren't just there for like reality
drama that's the first thing second
thing they play with honor so they'd be
like you the winner of the first round
gets to pick who opponent's gonna be the
second round it's like oh well you know
an American would just be like oh I can
beat this person so I'm gonna choose the
weakest one and I'm gonna do that and
then what they would do is they would go
to whoever they felt was the strongest
that would be the most honorable to
compete against and they'd be like it
would be my honor to compete against you
the whole thing's down to the subtitle
so I'm sorry I dubbed so it's like it's
all in Korean but then you're listening
on a dubbed thing which is hilarious
because there's even some guys that
speak English they dubbed them also in
more English it's hilarious so
so they that's how the show works and
they just eliminate people until they
get to the very end the final winner of
the physical 100 and so you this is like
you will love the show once you get in
you get two episodes deep you're gonna
love the characters which which body
type is best well I don't want to give
it away I mean this is this is the show
right so like this this is a giant
spoiler
um but you know you gotta have it all
you got to have attributes you got to
have the speed you gotta have the
strength you got to have the endurance
you gotta have the the dexterity you got
to have the the agility you got to have
it all because they test you in all
these different ways how would a show is
amazing you gotta watch this thing
physical 100 how would I do oh here's
the other thing that's great about it
they don't really edit it so like in an
American show they'll be like
the start of the competition then
there's like montage and then it's like
the big fight they'll spend five minutes
on the big argument the ending whereas
with this it's like these contestants
have one hour to pull this like 10 000
ton ship as a team to from one side of
this room to the other go and they just
show the whole thing in its entirety
it's even a little bit boring sometimes
but it's kind of like watching National
Geographic where you just get really
into it like planet Earth where you're
like oh is the lizard gonna get the ant
I gotta watch like and it's gonna just
happen I'm gonna watch the whole thing
play out you know with no no jump cuts
and it's such a refreshing change from
like Tick Tock and like these other
things that are like just such level
stuff I'm looking at the winner
uh we're not we're not that different
are we
well don't give it away you'd be
surprised why this person won it's it's
pretty crazy so so anyways yeah you got
to watch the show it's kind of amazing
all right that's it that's a pod
[Music]
foreign